>> Laura: THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING
LOW-COST HEALTH INSURANCE
ALTERNATIVES TO OBAMACARE AND
DEMOCRATS DO NOT LIKE IT AT ALL.
THE PLAN WOULD ALLOW HEALTH
INSURERS TO SELL SHORT TERM
POLICIES WITH LOWER COSTS AND
FEWER BENEFITS.
DEMOCRATS IMMEDIATELY RIDICULED
IT AS JUNK POLICY, TRASH,
GARBAGE, SENATOR CHUCK SCHUMER
RELEASED THE FOLLOWING
STATEMENT.
SINCE DAY ONE THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION PLAYBOOK ON
HEALTH CARE HAS BEEN A SABOTAGE
TO MARKET PLACES, JACKED UP
COSTS AND PREMIUMS FOR MILLIONS
OF MIDDLE-CLASS AMERICANS.
JOINING THE ANGLE EXCLUSIVELY TO
EXPLAIN THE PROPOSAL IS THE NEW
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
SECRETARY ALEX LAZAR.
MR. SECRETARY, THANKS FOR GIVING
US THE FIRST INTERVIEW.
THE BLOWBACK YOU GUYS ARE
GETTING FOR OFFERING AN
ALTERNATIVE IS WILD.
NANCY PELOSI SAYS AMERICANS
PURCHASING THEIR SHODDY,
MISLEADING, SHORT-TERM TRUMP
CARE PLAN WILL BE ONE DIAGNOSIS
AWAY FROM DISASTER.
IN OTHER WORDS, IT'S ARMAGEDDON.
>> THE SHOCKING THING IS THESE
PLANS WERE IN FACT AVAILABLE
UNTIL OCTOBER OF 2016 DURING THE
ENTIRETY OF THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION'S TENURE.
NOW WE ARE BRINGING THEM BACK.
THEY GOT RID OF THEM AT THE END
OF THE ADMINISTRATION AND SAID
YOU CAN ONLY HAVE THE PLANS THAT
WERE THREE MONTHS, THEY CUT THEM
DOWN TO THREE MONTHS, AND THEY
DON'T HAVE ANY OF THE OBAMACARE
RESTRICTIONS IN TERMS OF THE
MANDATE FROM THE CENTRAL
GOVERNMENT.
LESS FLEXIBLE SO PEOPLE CAN GET
LOWER COST PLANS IF THEY CHOOSE
TO.
>> Laura: NOW YOU ARE IN THESE
PLANS THAT ARE SUPPOSEDLY HEALTH
INSURANCE, BUT IT'S ACCESS.
PEOPLE DON'T GO TO THE DOCTOR AS
MUCH BECAUSE THE OUT-OF-POCKET
COSTS ARE SO HIGH, THE
DEDUCTIBLES ARE SO HIGH.
THEY SAY I HAVE INSURANCE, BUT
$3600 BEFORE I CAN TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF IT.
THOSE PEOPLE, THE MIDDLE-CLASS
WERE WERE STUCK IN THE AREA OF
THE ECONOMY WILL BEST BENEFIT
FROM THIS?
>> WE THINK A COUPLE DIFFERENT
GROUPS OF PEOPLE COULD BENEFIT
FROM THIS.
FIRST, THERE ARE PEOPLE FOR WHOM
THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT,
OBAMACARE'S INDIVIDUAL INSURANCE
PLANS ARE UNAFFORDABLE.
PREMIUMS DOUBLED BEFORE THE END
OF THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
INDIVIDUAL MARKET PREMIUMS HAVE
SOARED.
SO FOR MANY PEOPLE THE PLANS ARE
NOT AFFORDABLE TO GET, AND WHAT
THEY GET MAY NOT BE REAL
INSURANCE IN TERMS OF THE HIGH
DEDUCTIBLE YOU ARE TALKING
ABOUT.
FOR SOME OF THOSE PEOPLE, THESE
LESS EXPENSIVE PLANS, OFTEN
ONE-THIRD THE PRICE OBAMACARE
PLANS, MIGHT BE A GOOD OPTION
FOR THEM.
>> Laura: PRE-EXISTING
CONDITIONS, WHAT HAPPENS?
>> THESE PLANS DON'T HAVE THOSE
OBAMACARE MANDATES ABOUT
PRE-EXISTING CONDITIONS.
>> Laura: SO IF YOU HAVE LUNG
CANCER.
>> FOR SOMEBODY LIKE THAT OTHER
OPTIONS WOULD PROBABLY MAKE MORE
SENSE.
BUT FOR OTHER INDIVIDUALS, THESE
MAY BE THE CHEAPER --
>> Laura: YOUNG PEOPLE?
>> YOUNG PEOPLE, HEALTHY PEOPLE
THAT ARE ALREADY BEING SHUT OUT
OF THE OBAMACARE MARKETPLACE.
>> Laura: BECAUSE OF THE HIGH
COSTS.
>> BECAUSE THE WAY THE PLANS
WERE STRUCTURED, THE PREMIUMS
ARE SO HIGH FOR THE YOUNG AND
HEALTHY THEY'VE ARTIE BEEN
DRIVEN OUT OF THE MARKETPLACE.
OUR OPPONENTS TALK ABOUT THIS AS
IF WE ARE RIGHT NOW LIVING IN
THE LAND OF MILK AND HONEY AND
EVERYTHING IS PERFECT AND NOBODY
IS LACKING INSURANCE.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT 28 MILLION
FORGOTTEN MEN AND WOMEN WHO DO
NOT HAVE INSURANCE THAT WERE
PROMISED AFFORDABLE INSURANCE
AND PRESIDENT TRUMP WITH HIS
EXECUTIVE ORDER DEMANDED THAT WE
COME UP WITH SOLUTIONS AND
OPTIONS LIKE THIS FOR AFFORDABLE
INDIVIDUALIZED HEALTH INSURANCE.
>> Laura: YOU'RE JUST TRYING
TO KILL OFF OBAMACARE.
YOU'RE TRYING TO KILL IT OFF AND
AMERICA'S HEALTH INSURANCE
PLANS, THEY SAID WE REMAIN
CONCERNED THAT EXPANDED USE OF
SHORT-TERM POLICIES COULD
FURTHER FRAGMENT THE INDIVIDUAL
MARKET, WHICH WOULD LEAD TO
HIGHER PREMIUMS FOR MANY
CONSUMERS, PARTICULARLY THOSE
WITH PRE-EXISTING CONDITIONS.
WHY ARE THEY SO UPSET ABOUT
THIS, MR. SECRETARY?
>> THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
INSURANCE COMMISSION WAS IN THE
PAST VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THESE
EFFORTS TO CREATE THESE
AFFORDABLE OPTIONS FOR PEOPLE.
WE ARE TRYING TO MAKE OPTIONS
AVAILABLE FOR FOLKS WHO HAVE
BEEN SHUT OUT OF THE
MARKETPLACE.
WE NEED TO KEEP WORKING TO BUILD
A DIFFERENT SYSTEM THAN
OBAMACARE, BUT WHILE WE HAVE IT,
WE NEED MORE AFFORDABLE OPTIONS
FOR PEOPLE TO GET THE INSURANCE
THEY WANT, NOT WHAT I TELL THEM
THEY SHOULD HAVE.
>> Laura: WHY SHOULD A
55-YEAR-OLD MAN WHO IS UNMARRIED
HAVE TO PAY FOR BIRTH CONTROL IN
HIS POLICY?
WHY IS THAT SOMETHING?
>> WE WANT TO MAKE A SYSTEM
WHERE PEOPLE CAN BUY THE
INSURANCE THAT THEY WANT.
WE NEED TO WORK WITH CONGRESS TO
BE ABLE TO DO THAT.
>> Laura: THIS IS RULE-MAKING.
THIS IS RULE-MAKING TO GET 60
DAYS AND THEN IT GOES INTO
EFFECT.
>> THEN WE WOULD REVIEW THE
COMMENTS AND GO TO FIND A ROLE
AND THAT CAN BE EFFECTIVE
PERHAPS LATER THIS YEAR.
THESE ARE THINGS WE CAN DO WHILE
OBAMACARE IS STILL IN PLACE.
THINGS WE CAN DO TO HELP MAKE
INSURANCE MORE AFFORDABLE OR AT
LEAST GIVE OPTIONS TO PEOPLE.
LET'S SAY LOSE HER JOB.
>> Laura: ACTUALLY PAY FOR MY
OWN -- I'M ACTUALLY ONE OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS, A MARKETPLACE
PURCHASER, MY INSURANCE HAS GONE
UP 47% OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT,
IT'S CRAZY.
>> SO IF YOU LOSE YOUR JOB --
>> Laura: CAN YOU STOP SAYING
THAT PLEASE.
>> IF SOMEBODY ELSE LOSES THEIR
JOB.
>> Laura: I'M MUCH HAPPIER
WITH THAT.
>> WE ARE PROPOSING THAT THESE
PLANS WOULD BE AVAILABLE UP TO
12 MONTHS FOR PEOPLE.
SHORT-TERM PLANS.
>> Laura: SO AFTER 12 MONTHS?
>> WE ARE ASKING FOR COMMENT ON
WHETHER WE HAVE THE LEGAL
AUTHORITY TO LET PEOPLE RENEW
THEIR PLANS.
>> Laura: THAT'S A NEW HEALTH
ALTERNATIVE.
YOUNG PEOPLE, PEOPLE BETWEEN
JOBS, MIDDLE-CLASS PEOPLE, THE
POOR PEOPLE ARE TO GET COVERAGE,
THEY GET THE MEDICAID, THEY GET
COVERAGE.
BUT FOR THAT GROUP OF PEOPLE.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHERE YOU'RE
GETTING TRASHED.
I HAVE A FUNNIER JOB?
HE WAS FORMER DEPUTY SECRETARY
OF HHS.